[Musique]
elle aime faire de la politique en
chantant en dansant et parfois même en
criant dans le métro mon invité a le
sens du spectacle et elle le met au
service de l'action collective
[Musique]
bonjour Daniel Simonet bonjour alors
dans votre famille politique il y a le
style Mélenchon qu'on connaît bien qui
est fait d'éloquence des rudes
Daniel Simonet qui est un peu plus terre
à terre au contact des gens avec un
petit côté saltimbanque de la politique
comme on va le voir ici
jusque dans le métro parisien le Front
de Gauche mène campagne sans relâche
contre la Loi sur l'emploi est-ce qu'il
y en a beaucoup parmi vous qui vont au
travail ce matin
ça fait pas lourd hein forcément c'est
la crise on peut s'opposer à cette loi
refuser que les députés l'adoptent alors
ça c'est une criée dans le métro c'est
bien ça c'est vous qui avez inventé le
concept on peut le dire je trouve que ça
ça représente assez bien votre façon de
faire de la politique et d'ailleurs
j'avais envie de vous commencez
l'entretien on vous demandant de définir
votre façon de faire de la politique
mais c'est de vouloir impliquer le plus
grand nombre pour que
si on souhaite changer nos conditions de
vie et si on veut radicalement changer
la société il faut que le plus grand
nombre s'en mêle puisque aujourd'hui
bien les politiques elles sont souvent
faites par une petite poignée quoi ils
ont nous nous critiquons beaucoup la
Cinquième République sa logique
oligarchique et on souhaite vraiment que
le peuple s'approprie son destin puisse
écrire la Constitution et que les lois
Septent d'être faites sans le peuple et
contre le peuple c'est déclencher une
implication collective exactement une
implication collective alors vous avez
dit dans un article qui vous était
consacré que
votre conception de l'engagement c'était
de mettre vos tripes sur la table on le
sent on le voit dans dans cette archive
là mais cette façon de faire ça peut
aussi déranger ça peut aussi agacer par
exemple dans le métro là vous rentrez un
peu de force dans la vide et de ses
passagers en criant en essayant de les
faire réagir vous comprenez que ça
puisse aussi un peu agacer et bien en
fait
à chaque fois j'ai vraiment des
réactions des citoyens des citoyennes
majoritairement contents parce que
justement on se prend pas au sérieux et
en même temps fait passer un message
extrêmement sérieux et cette façon de
casser un peu les codes non c'est pas
parce qu'on est élu qu'on a un mandat
qu'on est au dessus des autres on est en
république très attachée à liberté
égalité fraternité et donc il faut je
pense assumer de casser les codes pour
permettre à tout le monde de se sentir
légitime pour s'engager dans la bataille
politique alors on va pas faire toute la
liste de vos happnings politiques mais
quand même vous avez fait défiler un
faux chameau à Paris Plage ça c'était
pour dénoncer la fermeture de lit à
l'hôpital de l'Hôtel-Dieu et puis vous
avez aussi mis en scène des poulets
géants plongeant dans une piscine ça
c'était pour dénoncer l'importation de
poulet au chlore américain de grand
marché transatlantique c'était un accord
de libre-échange avec les États-Unis
exactement et en fait aucun média n'en
parlait on fait cette cette action c'est
à penigne on se marre beaucoup à ce
moment-là ça fait un vrai buzz et du
coup on obtient ce qu'on voulait c'est à
dire un article pleine page du monde qui
va par cette entrée là aborder très
sérieusement comme nous le souhaitions
et bien les conséquences terribles des
accords de libre-échange donc vous avez
répondu à la question avant que je vous
la pose parce que moi ma question c'est
il y a un côté drôle amusant ça fait
sourire mais est-ce que c'est vraiment
efficace
sur les images mais est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est efficace est-ce que
c'est pas de la politique spectacle et
ben écoutez on est dans une société du
spectacle où on veut nous divertir cette
interdire nous nous ne pas faire en
faire en sorte que les citoyens se
préoccupent pas de la politique en les
divertissant nous au contraire on tord
ça et je fais l'inverse par la mise en
spectacle j'intéresse tout le monde à un
sujet extrêmement important par une
image par l'humour par le décalage alors
dans un registre très différent vous
avez aussi monté votre propre spectacle
un seul en scène très personnel très
politique le titre c'était uber les
et mes ovaires ça répondait à
quel besoin chez vous alors le besoin
d'abord de raconter
ce que j'avais découvert en soutenant de
manière un petit peu accidentelle en
fait la lutte des taxis et je prenais
conscience de l'ubérisation et à quel
point c'est un suicide social collectif
contre notre Code du Travail contre
notre système de protection sociale et
contre notre nos services publics aussi
par le biais de l'évasion fiscale et
puis j'avais aussi envie de parler de la
bataille féministe et à quel point
c'était important aussi quand une femme
en politique d'assumer de mener ce
combat là et finalement ce mode
d'expression la scène et bien parce
qu'en fait
elle libère complètement et elle permet
aussi donc de casser les codes et puis
vous savez c'est pas tout le monde qui
va ouvrir la porte pour aller dans une
salle et un meeting politique par contre
un spectacle vous invitez vos amis vos
voisins vos proches et donc le spectacle
la narration peut permettre justement
d'aborder la question politique et
j'aime beaucoup cette démarche voilà
d'éducation populaire et donc quand on
voit votre façon de faire de la
politique et bien moi je peux pas
m'empêcher de faire le lien avec votre
environnement familial vos parents qui
sont artistes sculpteurs on les voit sur
sur ces images vous assumez une forme
d'héritage familiale bien sûr moi cette
dimension artiste elle est un peu
présente alors de manière totalement
différente moi je suis très fière de mes
parents
en train de de sautiller devant une
grande chaise de mes parents qui a
[Musique]
solidarité de l'altérité de prendre
conscience qu'on est tous interdépendant
alors au collège vous vous êtes engagé
dans la lutte contre le racisme et puis
au lycée vous avez mis votre
établissement en grève contre la loi de
vaquer à l'époque vous dites j'ai
découvert le pouvoir de l'action
collective on y revient à cette idée là
quand vous avez pris conscience de ça
est-ce que c'est pas ce qui a déterminé
tout le reste de l'engagement c'est tout
d'un coup vous participez à la grève
vous participez à des manifestations et
vous n'êtes pas là isolé dans votre
lycée enfin la Seine-et-Marne vous
rendez compte que dans les médias ce
mouvement auquel vous vous sentez
appartenir et bien va changer le cours
de l'histoire puisqu'il va faire tomber
un gouvernement et nous allons gagner là
du coup je prends confiance de cela et
je souhaite aller à l'université pour
pouvoir m'engager pleinement je veux
faire de ma de ma vie un engagement
politique et participer avec d'autres à
changer le cours de l'histoire et c'est
à ce moment-là à la fac que vous
rejoignez le syndicat de l'UNEF et que
vous vous mobilisez notamment contre le
CIP le contrat d'insertion
professionnelle s'était en 1994
[Musique]
depuis le début ici à Créteil c'est
Daniel qui écrit les chansons c'est des
chansons c'est des chansons spécifiques
pour la manifestation ou ça nous permet
de dire qu'on a la victoire dire voilà
on a gagné on voulait pas nous écouter
on a fait le rapport de force on est
venu dans la rue pendant un mois on a
fait grève on a gagné quelle surprise à
l'époque c'est déjà vous qui écriviez
les chansons
dans les mobilisations syndicales c'est
important de mettre de la joie de la
joie et de l'énergie d'où votre surnom
Danette la mitraillette on comprend bien
en revoyant cette archive lunettes vous
a logiquement amené au Parti socialiste
c'était un peu la pouponnière du PS à
l'époque et au PS au moment de la guerre
du Golf vous êtes rapproché de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et puis en 2000 vous avez
rejoint son cabinet au ministère de
l'Enseignement professionnel vous dites
souvent que la politique façon techno
c'est pas votre truc qu'est-ce que vous
êtes allé faire dans un cabinet
mystérieux vous avez été heureuse et ben
c'était une expérience extrêmement
enrichissante dure à la fois en même
temps c'est extrêmement important de
comprendre comment comment ça se passe
de l'intérieur mais c'est vrai que
c'était pas évident puisque moi j'avais
très sérieux sur le perron du ministère
j'étais Conseillère d'Orientation
Psychologue psychologue de l'éducation
nationale maintenant on dit mais j'avais
un an d'exercice professionnel et je me
retrouve dans le cabinet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon délégal enseignement
professionnel pour travailler les
questions d'orientation scolaire et
professionnelle donc c'est très c'est
très difficile mais en même temps c'est
fondamental comme expérience parce qu'à
un moment donné il va falloir
désacraliser ses institutions là et se
dire notre objectif c'est la prise du
pouvoir pour pouvoir instaurer une autre
politique par la suite donc vous avez
suivi Jean-Luc Mélenchon au Parti de
gauche pendant toutes ces années vous
êtes battus pour les plus pauvres les
plus précaires tout en occupant un
logement de la ville de Paris avec un
loyer qui était sous les prix du marché
alors vous étiez pas dans une situation
illégale mais vos adversaires vous ont
reproché une forme de manque
d'exemplarité sur ce sujet là pourquoi
avoir attend est élu député pour rendre
ce logement en fait moi autour de moi
dans le 20e arrondissement personne ne
me le reprochait j'y étais avec les
droits c'est-à-dire que avec mes revenus
je ne serai pas élu j'y aurais droit de
la même manière donc il n'y avait
absolument aucun abus c'était pas un
hlmashow
avec un loyer subventionné le premier
jour où j'entre dans ce logement là il
est par ailleurs pas en dessous du
marché à ce moment là j'ai entre en 2003
et donc pourquoi l'avoir rendu en
devenant député bah parce que j'ai pas
du tout envie que ça revienne parce que
là on sait très bien que les médias ne
cherchent que ça de pouvoir attaquer la
France insoumise et puis qu'il est
revenu des députés sont différents donc
voilà je déménage enfin j'ai déménagé on
va conclure l'émission par notre quiz à
présent je vous explique le principe
c'est assez simple je vais commencer une
phrase et ce sera à vous de la compléter
c'est bon on y va on y va avant d'être
élu député je pensais que l'assemblée ce
serait très difficile de pouvoir
s'exprimer dans une dans une plénière
aussi intimidante le meilleur happning à
l'Assemblée serait de moi je trouve que
le fait qu'on ait changé la Marseillaise
au moment du 49-3 en brandissant nos
pancartes démocraties retrait du texte
de loi est extrêmement important parce
que c'est pas moi qui lui disais non non
mais je la trouve excellente parce qu'il
est important de rappeler d'où on vient
de la Révolution française c'est ce que
chante la Marseillaise et que ce mépris
démocratique du 49-3 montre qu'on a au
moins 49,3 bonnes raisons de vouloir
passer à une sixième république enfin
quand quelqu'un me confond avec Marine
Le Pen je vous dis ça parce que j'ai vu
dans un portrait que ça vous arrivez
dans la rue parfois alors en même temps
faut en rire mais il y a eu des fois des
quiproquos des gens désagréables avec
moi dans le 20e arrondissement vous
l'aurez compris l'extrême droite est pas
du tout
apprécié et bah oui bah écoutez c'est
aussi la preuve que il y a pas tant de
femmes que cela en politique et donc on
va confondre une blonde avec une autre
et bien non je n'ai rien à voir avec
avec Marine Le Pen et je suis
profondément attaché au partage des
richesses à la bataille écologique à la
Sixième République et à l'anti-racisme
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
Daniel Simonet d'être venu dans la
politique et moi
[Musique]